let's talk about the media because we
have this other story from the hill
the memo media face hard questions on
trump and the wuhan lab
i don't i don't really need i use i'll
use the article as a reference but i
don't think i need to actually pull
anything up because we all know what
happened
donald trump very early on said the
wuhan lab lab leak
which we should investigate into it the
media went nuts said it wasn't true
fauci said it was likely not true he's
like no i don't think so
everybody said trump was a conspiracy
theorist vox.com said theory debunked
and somehow for some reason all you know
all of a sudden the media's flipped on
this
and my my first point is like hey it's
about time people are taking this
seriously
and also wait a minute
what happened i don't just believe
all of these different media
institutions and political establishment
elites just decided
now oh i just realized maybe it's true
is there perhaps an agenda behind why
all of a sudden
they've decided to say yes let's
investigate wuhan
i'm not sure about that i think i
i doubt that the democrats and the
overall
you know media consensuses we want to
toughen up on china and demonize china
worse now
i'm not saying like they've they've
coordinated anything like the media i
think is just deferential to what
the polit the establishment elites say
apparently to me
what made the change was a guy i forget
his name
sims maybe uh who had been the new york
times science reporter for like 30 years
and this is not the guy that got fired
over saying the n word this is a
different guy
different guy okay not the n-word guy
and that story was completely ridiculous
so this is the other guy and and they
wouldn't publish the thing at the new
york times he just published it at
medium.com
but it's i don't know how many words it
says at the top 47 minute read
wow so it's like a 20 000 word article
or something
about how geez guys we don't have the
proof but it really does look like
it was the lab and then but that means
man-made or manipulated like uh fouchy
said he wasn't convinced it was
naturally occurring
right so and this is the deal it's this
gain of function
research where they deliberately make
viruses more and more deadly
on the theory that they can keep it
locked up in the lab and that then they
can anticipate
future viruses if we're going to
engineer a virus that attacks the ace
ace2 receptor
on your lung cells and then we're going
to figure out how to kill that virus
so that then if a virus similar to this
ends up breaking out
into the public we'll know how to fight
it so that's the theory
but of course it's really dangerous work
because what they're doing is they're
deliberately evolving these viruses to
be more and more
contagious more and more transmissible
because otherwise it takes too long
and then to go through the steps so you
have to make it as infectious as
possible
so you can hurry up and do the next
stage of the experiment but they were
doing it in
a lab that we we had repeatedly heard
warnings about for
having lacked security procedures when
obama outlawed it so
it was the was the obama white house
requested that congress
outlaw this and they could have done it
just by executive order or something i
guess
they had congress pass a law and and ban
this
but the law has a loophole that says
that if the proper authority
determines that there's a national
emergency then you can go ahead
when it was fouchy and you signed off on
the national emergency but
we can't go ahead here but we can
finance this group
that's financing the research president
we got to slow down uh and we jumped the
connection
okay the u.s was providing funding to
this lab
right so can you explain yeah so so as
under the national institutes of health
then there's a subcontractor i'm sorry i
forgot the name of the
the company that's the subconscious go
health or something yeah exactly
something like that yeah and then
those guys were actually the ones in
charge of the investigation as to what
happened
everybody took their word i love it
found ourselves
innocent of any wrongdoing by the way so
at the beginning
when you said everybody denounced trump
that's not exactly right the head of the
cdc at the time
the bald guy with the beard i'm sorry i
forgot his name uh that's not right
field is it yes
yes redfield said he thought that it was
that it must have been engineered in a
lab
and the guy and the the famous and nobel
laureate virologist
said the same thing luke what's his name
i don't remember his name um he's called
the conspiracy theory said it was he was
he was nuts but see you all
they're like oh well fouchy said it so
well and you also have josh rogan
who is you know very close to the war
party and writes for the washington post
and he's just put out a new book about
this as well
that says like we don't have the proof
but boy
does it sure look like this must be what
happened but i don't
so a lot of people have mentioned this
this medium post and there was one viral
tweet that was like think about that
the only reason this story is getting
out is because someone wrote a story on
medium because our media establishment
wouldn't accept it
and the new york times wouldn't publish
their own science reporter but but right
right but
we had we've had whistleblowers we we
had a a a researcher
out of the university of hong kong
saying looked like a lab leak and they
knew people
who were involved in it and that was all
rejected all lies all conspiracy
trump said without evidence trump said
without evidence right all of a sudden
now this guy writes this medium post
so here's what it is here's what it is
it's not so much about why are they
open to the possibility now as much as
why did they refuse to discuss this
possibility all last
year and you already hit the key there
because it was trump that said it
yeah and they had an agenda to hang the
virus around
his neck no matter what so
and frankly you know his leadership
on the issue the first few months there
was not so much to be admired and so
this was the thing that they're going to
use as the millstone to hang around his
neck
now if the virus came out of the lab in
china china
china that fits in with his narrative
and is handing him a point maybe a few
points
and now what's interesting though right
is that they could have turned it right
back around again
although they would have had to
sacrifice their boy fauci
they would have had to say that actually
it is trump's fault because trump wasn't
doing his job
preventing fauci from signing this
emergency authorization
to allow this virus to go on so they
could have still made it all trump's
faults anyway
but they would have had to go around the
long way yeah and it was easier to just
say well it came from nature
and this guy just did nothing but sit on
his hands and that's why everybody's
dead and there's no way they were going
to let
this complicated story break out in the
summer
there's become a real topic of
conversation if they could squelch it
and they did squelch it
they did not want to give trump an
opportunity for a win period so no
matter what he said
it was bad and so the media was just
their bread and butter the whole time
now cnn's ratings just on fire msnbc
everyone's in the gutter because it was
just
that's what they were living off of
anger at donald trump but let me tell
you
it's really easy to criticize the media
i think most people get it at this point
i'll tell you what's shocking to me this
story which just went up
uh like was it like now 40 minutes ago
from fox news
senate advances measure barring taxpayer
funds for china's wuhan institute of
virology
amendment added by gop senator joni
ernst of
iowa to the endless frontier act which
seeks to counter china
only now it's been a year and a half
well almost a year and a half of they
already had a law like this why don't
they just take out the part that says
that fauci can sign an emergency
authorization yeah that's all they gotta
do is why didn't they fire that guy
you know i will say i would love to see
one if there's one debate that i could
see between you know a couple people
would be fouchy debating fouchy
with fauci stepping in because fauci's
been anti-mask he's been pro mask
he said go on cruises he said cruises
are dangerous he said it's not going to
be a big deal it's going to be a really
big deal
he said uh two masks it's just common
sense he said two masks if there's no
there's no evidence suggesting and then
he said
cdc guidelines say you should wear two
masks he's just like trump
he's on all sides of every issue so you
can pick and choose and if you want to
like them then you can go out
with half of the stuff this guy says
that's pretty good we need him
so i i know like you mentioned the other
day uh lydia that crowder had a uh
you know fouchy debating fauci but we
need an updated fouche debating fauci
because boy part two yeah he could
really debate himself
you know why he you know why he was
first famous was because
when the aids epidemic was first
breaking out in the 1980s
he was the guy who pushed that no we
must only fund vaccine research
and we must do everything we can to
thwart people who are trying to come up
with medications to treat it
now here we are in the year 2021
there's no aids vaccine yeah there's no
vaccine for hiv there never has been
they've
you know tried working on it from time
to time um
the reason well i don't know but the
reason that
people survive with aids now is because
of the drugs
that fauchi suppressed and you know i
saw on twitter someone
uh showed an old sign of uh aids rally
and from like 1984 or 1985
and the guy says the guy's sign says dr
fauci you're killing us
wow really yeah i i i just i we got this
next story from
about and it was azt was the big drug
that he was trying to suppress
and that was the first big breakthrough
drug that helped aids patients
wow wait azt yeah is is that the same
drug that's been brought up as a
azithromycin
or no i don't know no i don't know well
so they made a matthew mcconaughey movie
out of this the drug buyers club or was
it the buyers club oh yeah dallas buyers
club yeah where this is it's aids
patients and dr fauci
won't let them buy medicine so they got
to go down to mexico to get the
medicines
that's who this guy is 40 years he's
been entrenched in this industry at
least
and seriously let's just entertain the
possibility for a second because it's
not proven yet okay but let's just say
that
he signed this emergency authorization
that allowed the money to go to this
subcontractor to continue pushing this
research at wuhan fauci just killed a
couple of million people
including about 600 000 americans i
don't know what was the last count of
number of americans who died of this
thing but i guarantee you it's higher
than the official council the excess
death rate is much higher
let's do some math and be fair all right
um if everybody wore a mask from the
get-go
according to the cdc that would have
helped prevent the spread
so they say uh okay well then if
everybody did there'd be a lot less debt
right
well in the beginning fauci said not to
wear a mask because he wanted to make
sure the doctors got it right he later
admitted that that
well you know we said that because we
were worried the doctors wouldn't get it
right as i pointed out yesterday
the reason the doctors need the masks is
because people aren't wearing masks
it's because people don't wear masks get
sick and then go to the hospital and so
the doctors need to wear them too
right if everybody was wearing masks
you'd have a lot less people in
hospitals doctors wouldn't need as many
fauci lied and people died and he could
have just said listen
please for the love of god everybody
save the n95s for the doctors
yes but wear two bandanas or something
yeah he could have said wear a scarf
sure i mean people walk around with
masks they take a handkerchief he could
he could he could've said you don't need
the n95s just pull your shirt up and put
something over your face instead he lied
because he was worried that people would
buy the medical supplies although you
know at this point
and honestly i don't read up on the germ
nearly as much as i was a year ago
uh so i am behind on this but it really
looks like the masks are red herring
because you know tom woods uh sends out
his daily email and one of the things
that he's constantly doing is comparing
the states
with the different levels of mask
mandate at the same time and the curves
are always
well this just got i think they have
studies that say that like if you and i
are wearing masks we're less likely to
transfer it to each other
here and now in this room but if you try
to extrapolate that out and say you have
to
everyone in virginia what must wear a
mask it doesn't work and it doesn't make
it
you got to wash your mask too well
here's here's and the reason
wait one more thing the reason they
thought the masks worked so well in the
first place was because
in countries like south korea and in
china and hong kong and taiwan
they were all wearing masks and not
getting very sick
but that wasn't what it was it only
seemed like it was because they have a
much stronger immunity to coronavirus
because they're exposed to many more
coronaviruses than we do so here's
here's the big challenge right now we've
seen texas and florida
they they dropped everything they said
we're open for business and a bunch of
republican states are the same thing
and joe biden comes out and this was
this was months ago he was like we're
gonna we might need a longer lockdown
and more restrictions
and everyone was joking like go to
florida who's biden talking to
the problem is youtube we're at risk
right now of getting totally pulled off
just for even bringing this up
there have been channels that have been
outright deleted with no warning
for simply mentioning what you just said
but what are we supposed to do when we
have clear examples
in the political arena of states and
then when fauci is brought on the today
show and they say how do you explain
this he goes i can't
right then why are we listening to this
guy a tv doctor
who doesn't know what he's talking about
and for some reason
they act like he's an expert they make
action figures of him they call it the
fauci ouchie
that is a cult i'm sorry this guy's not
an expert he clearly doesn't know what
he's talking about
right and they're acting like what he
says is gospel i like tucker carlson's
take on this he goes you know
this guy with all his lockdowns and all
his recommendations
i think maybe he's over compensating for
something here
that this guy he's known all along he's
the one who did this to us
he's the one who unleashed this virus on
the planet
and now he's going around talking about
how you and you and you aren't doing
enough
to protect yourself i thought you were
going to say something else are there so
have you
one second do you remember the episode
of the simpsons where they
i don't know what happened there was
like a council took over
and then comic book guy is like trying
to pass a law and he goes like
we as the most logic logical species in
the galaxy the vulcans
mating will now be will will now take
place only once every seven years
for most of you this will be much much
less mating but for me much much more
yeah so the joke would be foul she's
like we're going to lock down because
then
you know nobody can have you know in the
uk they actually you couldn't have
you couldn't go and have sex with
somebody like you actually banned that
stuff
is there that's where i thought you were
going i was like fauci's like he's an
old man are there examples of gain of
function
do it working i don't know that's a good
question like
whether they actually ever preempted a
naturally occurring virus because
they've been doing such a good job
experimenting on possible ones i don't
think so
i think we would have heard of that
right well that's not how they stop
mirrors that's not how they stop sars
they stopped those because you had to
have a really high fever to spread it
and so they were able to just
lock everybody down and i think star
spread to canada
and they just kept it in one city and it
never but from there we're not supposed
to know about what's going on in the wan
lab
and we don't know about what's going on
in american labs to us to a great degree
a lot of it's just
classified secret and the american labs
have better security
protocols so better if this it's looking
more and more like
lab leak is legit i mean the wall street
journal said three people from the lab
were hospitalized
hospitalized with this with some some
similar illness and they only told us
that
two days ago that's right that's right
and they knew the reports from 29 was it
the report was from last year i think
right yeah it was a cia report and you
would get banned on youtube for saying
it
you would get banned on youtube for
saying all of these things the media is
now saying oh yeah i guess so
fauci himself coming out and saying this
and it's like i gotta go i gotta worry
about censorship
so back we were right back to the larger
point about the media right
and this is a headline i actually didn't
get a chance to read it yet but i saw
matt tybee's new piece it's called the
death of fact checking yes oh yeah
that's it how is it how is glenn kessler
at the washington post going to pretend
to be a fact checker anymore
when he's not right he doesn't know what
the hell he's talking about
effect claimed they debunked tucker
carlson's show
because they got an expert to give their
opinion that is not how you debunk
something
if someone makes a video and there is an
eagle that picks up a baby and flies
away which is like it was a viral video
that happened at some point
you debunk it by investigating the
source material
putting it through like an analysis to
track like the you know like
um light and artifacts in the in the
video and then point to it and say
here's my
my my proposal i believe this is
evidence and then you have an expert
opinion breaking down all the facts
right just having some guy go on tv and
say he's got an opinion
i got an opinion okay yours is the
correct opinion thank you have a nice
day
that's not debunking anything all right
look they say trust the science but what
they mean is trust the scientists
that we have here saying things when
science itself is nothing but a process
for debunking things
it's not something to be trust i mean
you can trust it in the sense that
it's an effective way to try to debunk
things but it's not
a set of answers in a book somewhere
that you just
instead of god we have science now so we
just believe whatever he says
but right there there's nobody there we
have we have this guy i want to show you
this will compete real quick luke
montagne he is a french virologist and
the joint recipient of the francois
barra sinui i'm pronouncing it wrong
and blah blah blah of the 2008 nobel
prize in physiology of medicine
for his discovery of the human
immunodeficiency virus hiv
down over chronovirus pandemic they say
the sun is wikipedia page
montagnier argued that the coronavirus
disease 2019 was man-made in a
laboratory
and that it might have been the result
of an attempt to create a vaccine for
hiv
his allegations came after the united
states had launched a probe into whether
the virus came from a laboratory
according to maintagnia the presence of
elements of hiv and germ of malaria in
the genome of the chronovirus is highly
suspect
for and the characteristics of the virus
could not have arisen naturally
initially this was described as a
conspiracy
vision that does not relate to real
science by jean francois
del fracy probably pronouncing that
wrong an immunologist and the head of
the scientific council
that advises the french government on
the coven pandemic however
anthony fauci the director of the
national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases
admitted on may 11 2021 that he no
longer is convinced
that covet 19 originated naturally
this guy was called a conspiracy
theorist and he is a nobel prize-winning
virologist
and only now because fauci agrees with
him we're supposed to now say okay no no
when the when the when the
award-winning virologist comes out and
says here's what i think we go wow i
mean he's the expert right
hey there so the cdc said the same thing
but let me point this out
when tucker carlson has a guest on the
show who can
cite an award-winning nobel laureate
for his hypothesis not even statement of
fact
and politifact says we got some guy who
gave us his opinion that you're wrong so
it's debunked
and then vox and all these other outlets
and cnn can say it's fake news now how
is it reality
for these fact checkers when they don't
the experts the actual award-winning
experts are at odds with them
who are these random people they put in
the news and then claim our experts to
debunk what you're saying
it's fake news they're writing fake
stories this vox reporter i tweeted
about this
she wrote a fabricated story vox.com
wrote
fake news when is any of these fact
checkers going to come out i need these
organizations
newsguard i'm talking to you i use you
guys i reference
news guard who get who cites are you
gonna go now to every single one of
these outlets that
debunked lab leak with no evidence and
and their debunk was an opinion from
some guy
and now claim they publish fake news
what if i get a former cia official
who comes and talks about some crazy
conspiracies involving aliens well i got
a cia official it must be true
they do this all the time they pick and
choose based on what they think is
socially acceptable but you know what
there's a reason why your show
pulls more viewers than any show on cnn
that's because people are over it in the
key demo
they got the old people okay yeah yeah
we got the younger people and remember
too by the way i had forgotten about
this but there were two indian
virologists at the very beginning who
said they thought it was a lab leak
because of the presence of what they
recognized as pieces of hiv
and some of them they were told that
they were complete kooks remember that
and some of them
some of these uh initial reports these
initial publications were retracted
because the media said so because people
were scared that reputations would be
destroyed
well this guy this luke montagna guy
he's he's 88 i'm sure he doesn't care
much about anything at this point he's
like i'm just going to say it
and it's it's this first of all
please use this as an another example we
often have many examples
to your friends and family when they're
like i trust the media say
here you go here you go fauci is now
admitting they called
the nobel prize winner who discovered
aids a conspiracy hiv sorry a conspiracy
theorist
for saying in my expert opinion having
discovered
hiv this is what i think about this they
were like conspiracy
what he he didn't he didn't say it was a
conspiracy
he didn't suggest a group of people came
together to commit a crime in secret
he's just like people do gain a function
all the time in fact if you go back a
year
what they would say about this always in
fact i remember tucker carlson
refuting the debunking of his show
is they put words in his mouth that he
said it was a
biological weapon that had that was
being used deliberately
i never said anything about a weapon
nobody ever thought nobody ever claimed
that if somebody's working on germs in a
laboratory that that's
biological weapons research what we
think
may have happened here was somebody
accidentally got infected which happens
and then they spread it and it got out
to the world
oh no you're developing the stephen king
they made a movie the stand and they
were working on a virus in like florida
and one of them
emergency and then everyone's like
freaking out one of the employees is
like
i gotta get out i gotta save my family
and get out of the city they lock the
whole city down he like
escapes and gets his family and flees to
texas gets to a gas station and spreads
it to like eight people and then that's
how
or like in uh 28 days later when they
have the chimp infected and they're
doing experiments
and then the the eco animal activists
free it no
zombies spread or whatever this is what
the fact checkers mine that's why
they're so afraid of this idea of a lab
leak is because of movies like that
this is what fact checkers do at these
organizations like snopes and like
politifact
they'll say something like oh you know
scott horton's here on the tim cats
podcast and
fact check did you know people will be
people have claimed on twitter that
scott horton appeared on the tim cast
irl show
question did scott horton appear on the
tim cast irl podcast
dot dot dot with ice cream false
yeah and then it's like no one ever said
he had ice cream but they add that tiny
little bit that makes no sense
and the whole thing becomes fake and
then at the bottom they'll say you know
they'll give you a bunch of verbose
garbage you don't want to read where
it'll be like in 20 you know in 2017
toon pool dude you got the idea for
putting a show and i'll talk about this
nonsense and then right at the bottom in
one sentence
while he did appear on the show he did
not have ice cream
so people see these fact checks and they
screen cap and they share with their
friends
see it's false it's not true actually
read it why don't you
that's what the media does you got to
share this stuff
you lie to people so many times in a row
you radicalize the hell out of them and
make them mad as hell i mean this is the
deal
you can't just keep doing the same thing
over and over and over to people
because it stops working i hope that
fauci will be
one of the greatest tools in waking
people up to the lies
of the establishment and the media just
we need just like a thirty second clip
of fouchy contradicting himself in
really
dumb ways and you can feel like it's
really proven that he did this
that this really does come from his
so what the what the fact check said is
well you know so so rand paul
questioned fauci in in this
congressional hearing and fauci denied
providing we never funded any of this
you are
wrong and that's not true the funding
was provided
but what was really funny is politifact
said well they were
technically doing gain of function
research but there's different
definitions of what that means so
it's not necessarily true but what
really happened
is that yes there was money provided by
the nih but it
was kind of like a general pool wasn't
allocated so even though they used some
of it for gain of function we don't
it's like did they really basically what
they're saying is well
they didn't explicitly sign off do gain
a function research therefore rand paul
is wrong
so like if you were building this but
they did if you were building a skate
park and i was like well here let me
allocate a bunch of money to you to do
whatever you want with it and you're
like okay i'll build
this skate park with it and i'm like and
then when i didn't give you money to
build a skate park
right i gave you money you were building
a skate park and you used it to build
the skates
so we'll break it down ian ian get puts
a million dollars up
timp will build a skate park with that
money and then when someone says
ian you funded the creation of this
skatepark he goes no i didn't
and then the fact check says false ian
provided a million dollars for general
purposes
it wasn't to build the skate park while
it is true that tim poole built a skate
park
and there it is yes the money came from
the u.s government from this source
yes it went to wuhan yes they did this
thing but they didn't
mean to that's the media that's the game
they the weird thing is
i am more comfortable and at ease with
this whole thing knowing it's from a lab
than thinking it just came from nature
well you don't know it's from a lab
assuming that it
thinking if i could pick thinking that
we were working on a virus that
infected some people and and it is way
easier and like good okay at least we're
trying to do something
as opposed to just naturally some random
virus came and started destroying
humanity
in fact the sars and mers were like the
two novel viruses from the last 20 years
and luckily and they were very dangerous
but they were only very dangerous to a
small number of people they were able to
contain them
so so so this is actually one of the
hypotheses
is that they were bringing bats in
because they were doing experiments on
covet on the bat coronavirus because of
how dangerous it was
and the gain of function research was an
attempt to create a vaccine i'm not
saying that's true
those are some of the theories that are
in some of these mainstream publications
talking about what may have happened
and then it leaked from the lab there
was a story about uh i i we covered this
we talked about on the show
that one of the people got sprayed with
like bat urine or something someone got
bit
so these stories were already out there
but you run the risk
of google banning you if you dare bring
it up
the double standard the media is allowed
to claim everything's a conspiracy
theory
they're allowed to determine what is or
isn't true and google just allows it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you